do I worry for you yeah I have some
worries I worry what's going to happen
when you wake up tomorrow at one in the
afternoon
do you realize that you're not going to
be the host of The Daily Show anymore
yeah you're just going to be a
best-selling author who does comedy and
sold out Arenas around the world
#pray for Trevor
[Laughter]
comedian Neil Brennan serving as the
final guest on The Daily Show with
Trevor Noah you might say the Emmy
nominated writer and comedian plays well
with others he helped Dave Chappelle
achieve stardom with the Innovative
sketch comedy show they co-created and
co-wrote he's also directed specials for
Seth Meyers Michelle wolf and other
Comics but now Brennan's back to his own
stand-up routes and back in the
spotlight with blocks his second Netflix
special Jamie wax caught up with the
comedian in Los Angeles to hear more
about his multi-faceted comedy career
talking to a white lady she's just I had
no idea things were so bad between black
people and the police I was like yeah
there's no way you could have known
unless you listen to any song by a black
person ever Neil Brennan is known for
pushing the limits of just how far
comedy can go yeah I did all the
Catholic Milestones baptism First Holy
Communion confirmation atheism right
both as a ripe
and as a performer do you consider
yourself a solo artist or a stand-up
comic or do you think there there should
be no no boundary I think of myself as a
stand-up comic chiefly and then
in order to make the shows a little more
Dynamic I'll throw a little you know
something yeah
good question Neil would you rather be
right or would you rather be happy and I
was like oh
that something is on Full display and is
innovative confessional specials like
three mics yeah I was lucky enough to
have dropped out
um because I realized early on that
these these student loans are basically
small business loans and the business is
you
and you're maybe not such a great
business
this latest special blocks when I think
about when this show was taped and when
we're sitting here now
it's unbelievable how many things within
a short time but that commented on that
could have been today yes but the
American life is sort of
history doesn't repeat itself but it but
it Rhymes I am afraid of guns but it
turns out the cops are too
the guns aren't going away Kanye's not
going away weed's not going away
alcohol's not going away racism's not
going away and uh gender differences
aren't going away Brennan's interesting
comedy started in childhood as the
youngest of 10 kids in an Irish Catholic
Family and both my parents were born
during the Great Depression and they
were nice enough to bring it with them
that's the first time you realize this
actually might be what you do for a
living I remember a moment from my life
when I was
when when Eddie Murphy is not sorry I
left
so I'm eight and nine
my parents had pulled in the driveway I
wasn't supposed to be up watching sorry
live so I'd have to run upstairs and hop
in bed and at a certain point
I said to my mom hey you need to let me
watch Saturday Night Live it's important
I'm eight I remember as I said it I was
like what are you even saying I didn't
even know what I was saying I just knew
when I saw
SNL and I was like it's something about
it was like a beacon to me his passion
for the craft stayed with him until
college but not for long when he started
being part of New York City's stand-up
scene on the side I was going to film
school I was like something about this
feels better than that so I dropped up
and started making 235 dollars a week
working the door to Comedy Club barking
people inside I was not good at it and
they called me they called me no show
Neil the connections he made in New York
led to more and more opportunities over
the years
including co-creating co-writing and
co-executive producing one of the most
groundbreaking and popular sketch shows
of all time Chappelle's Show
this idea of telling the truth but
poking something important in the eye in
a way came about working with Chappelle
is that fair
I I was what I was like before I met
Dave and then I think part of the reason
we worked well together was because
we're if not temperamentally similar or
even ideologically similar a level of
respect for each other's intellect and
point of views a lot of times they
matched when they didn't I would we
would just use my point of view to
sharpen his point of view
welcome to Chappelle Show I still
haven't been canceled yet
but I'm working on it at the height of
the show's popularity Chappelle famously
and suddenly quit I was on set waiting
for him what was that like for you awful
it's horrible probably the worst period
of my life I would argue I knew what he
meant I didn't agree with the approach
and etc etc
I like to believe that my ways of being
Brennan's career and comedy have
continued to evolve he's become more
introspective my emotions and even more
willing to share that part of himself
with his audience I like to believe that
they're not defects they're grateful for
the emotional part that's another thing
no one talks about the vulnerability I
show in blocks and in three mics is not
that common here we go just two guys
walking down Sunset Boulevard oh well
look it's where you started yeah it's
where I do most of my shows and although
Neil Brennan has come a long way since
his early days in stand-up
does this not work for you is this good
blocking such a surprise he's content
for now to stay right where he is I've
kind of gotten weirdly less ambitious I
don't want my life to be ruined by
ambition I want purpose but I don't want
a heart attack so I feel like that's
where I am and my life is manageable
maybe it's
it's one with me right maybe I'm too
cranky or wounded or misogynistic or
something I don't even know I am right
you know what I realized recently
it's not me
well good let's end the show good night
everybody
foreign
CBS Saturday morning Jamie wax Los
Angeles
I love that line I didn't want my life
to be ruined by ambition I wanted
purpose but not a heart attack I love
that he gets so emotional and
introspective because it is rare to see
that at that level in comedy he uh I
think some of those moments that we were
all laughing at and it's with all
comedians are those moments because you
go
totally relate totally related funny and
it's a little bit harsh yeah but it's
also true true a little truth in comedy
yeah